Katrina: 这是谁啊
Katrina: Who is this?
Shure: 啊看我笑的多灿烂啊
Shure: Ah, look how brightly I'm smiling.
Shure: 啊我又暗淡了
Shure: Ah, now I'm dim again.
Shure: 老板知道为什么我暗淡了吗
Shure: Boss, do you know why I'm dim?
Jack: 因为没给钱是吧
Jack: Because you didn't get paid, right?
Shure: 因为我想涨工资
Shure: Because I want a raise.
Jack: 啊
Jack: Ah.
Shure: 可以了可以了可以了
Shure: That's enough, enough, enough.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 慢点慢点慢点慢点慢点
Katrina: Slow down, slow down, slow down, slow down.
Jake:准时
Jake: On time.
Shure: 懂懂
Shure: Got it.
Shure: 这叫什么
Shure: What's this called?
Shure: 音乐脱口秀
Shure: Musical talk show.
Shure: 懂了吧
Shure: Got it?
Jake: 可以
Jake: Okay.
Alice:你这状态持续多久了
Alice: How long have you been in this state?
Jack: 这是有有病
Jack: This is sick.
Jack: 有病得治
Jack: You need treatment.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Sigh.
Katrina: 你弹的够悲伤的
Katrina: You played that so sadly.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Nicous: 妈的 跟着修硕这节奏
Nicous: Damn, following Shure's rhythm.
Shure: 有一种
Shure: It's kinda...
Shure: 怎么我的诗朗诵不好吗
Shure: What's wrong? Wasn't my poetry recital good?
Katrina: 特别好都想哭了
Katrina: It was so good it almost made me cry.
Jack: 太好了
Jack: That was amazing.
男嘉宾:关了
Male Guest: Turn it off.
Shure: 我都不知道难忘今宵的歌词是啥
Shure: I don't even know the lyrics to "Unforgettable Tonight."
Jake:就就这个
Jake: It's just this one.
Shure: 难忘今宵
Shure: "Unforgettable Tonight."
Shure: 我们大家一起大合唱
Shure: Let's all sing together.
刘婷:这是你们的固定节目吗
Liu Ting: Is this your usual routine?
Jack: 我们来点年头小点的吧
Jack: Let's pick something a bit newer.
Alice:哈哈是吧
Alice: Haha, right?
Shure: 年头小点的歌
Shure: A song that's a bit newer.
Shure: 怎么你你哈哈哈
Shure: What are you... haha.
Jack: 哎这个可以可以
Jack: Hey, this one works.
Jake:难忘哈哈哈
Jake: "Unforgettable" haha.
Katrina: 他改精神攻击了
Katrina: He switched to mental attacks now.
Jack: 你就会这一句是吧
Jack: You only know this one line, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yep.
Jake:不行了不行
Jake: Can't do it anymore.
Jake:你还要加工资
Jake: And you still want a raise.
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Jake:你还要加工资
Jake: And you still want a raise.
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Jack: 这应该 是后经也损人位是吧
Jack: This should be the post-also damaging, right?
Shure: 大家有有什么想听的歌吗
Shure: Does anyone have a song they want to hear?
Shure: XBZ都会弹
Shure: XBZ can play anything.
Nicous: 我会库吗
Nicous: Can I?
Nicous: 哎呀这终于恢复正常了
Nicous: Ah, finally back to normal.
Nicous: 来来来找个什么歌唱什么
Nicous: Come on, come on, let's find a song to sing.
Shure: 唱什么
Shure: What to sing?
Shure: 你刚才说什么
Shure: What did you just say?
Shure: 不会
Shure: No idea.
Jack: 看起来可以唱
Jack: Looks like you can sing.
女嘉宾:真的很会唱啊
Female Guest: You really can sing.
Jack: 能唱就唱
Jack: If you can sing, then sing.
Shure: 给大家表演一个
Shure: Let me perform something for everyone.
Shure: 每次都会在酒后给大家表演的
Shure: Every time after drinking, you always put on a show for everyone.
Shure: 叫什么来着哈哈
Shure: What was it called again, haha.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Go ahead.
Alice:本人不伤心
Alice: I'm not sad.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Go ahead.
Alice:试这个点心
Alice: Try this snack.
Shure: 就四个和弦
Shure: It's just four chords.
Shure: 你往低了点弹不就得了吗
Shure: Why don't you play it a bit lower?
Shure: 哎呀我都能
Shure: Oh, I can even...
Shure: 弹到哪了
Shure: Where did you get to?
Shure: 就1645四个和弦
Shure: Just 1-6-4-5, four chords.
Shure: 我我我我我怎么怎么起的啊
Shure: How, how, how did I start it?
Shure: 哎怎么怎么卧槽
Shure: Oh, how did, oh crap.
Jack: 我又寡言掉了你懂个叫我行不
Jack: I went silent again, can you call me out?
Shure: 我我我我最啊我最爱
Shure: I, I, I love, I love...
Shure: 卧哎卧槽
Shure: Oh, oh crap.
Shure: 哈哈哈等一下
Shure: Hahaha, wait a second.
Alice:气急败坏
Alice: Frustrated.
Shure: 啊啊啊找到了
Shure: Ah, ah, ah, found it.
Shure: 谢谢大家谢谢大家
Shure: Thank you, everyone, thank you.
Shure: 好了我们的egoKTV
Shure: Okay, our egoKTV...
Nicous: 下一首
Nicous: Next song.
Jake: 下一首
Jake: Next song.
Shure: 别下一首了哈哈哈
Shure: No more next songs, haha.
Shure: 一会老底都揭没了怎么办
Shure: What if all our secrets get revealed?
Jack: 下一首
Jack: Next song.
Shure: 哎大家大家
Shure: Hey, everyone, everyone.
Shure: 还会唱什么
Shure: What else can you sing?
Alice:过来点
Alice: Come closer.
Lucia:嗯
Shure: 还听过什么
Shure: What else have you heard?
Shure: 就是能大家一起调动氛围一起唱的
Shure: Something that can get everyone involved and singing together.
Lucia:想你了
Lucia: Miss you.
Shure: 想你了
Shure: Miss you.
Lucia:哦不不不
Lucia: Oh no, no.
Shure: 想谁了哈哈哈
Shure: Who do you miss, haha?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Lucia:人家想我了哈哈
Lucia: They miss me, haha.
Shure: 哎呀想想想想
Shure: Oh yeah, miss, miss, miss.
Shure: 别普通朋友了哈哈
Shure: Don't just be ordinary friends, haha.
Shure: 老老在这唱这多晦气是吧哈哈
Shure: Singing here is such bad luck, right? Haha.
Shure: 什么东西
Shure: What is this?
Shure: 你这什么风格
Shure: What's this style?
Jack: 你今天弹这个
Jack: You're playing this today?
Jack: 应该有很多什么情歌之类的
Jack: Should be a lot of love songs or something like that.
Jack: 就流沙嘛
Jack: Like quicksand.
Jack: 爱情好像流沙
Jack: Love is like quicksand.
Jack: 不复挣扎嘛
Jack: Can't struggle anymore.
Lucia:出现
Lucia: Appear.
Shure: 我这就
Shure: I'm just...
Lucia:你今天晚上住这边吗
Lucia: Are you staying here tonight?
Shure: 主要已经脱离了那个唱苦情歌的阶段
Shure: Mainly, I've moved past the stage of singing sad love songs.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
男嘉宾:有了对像了是吧
Male Guest: You have someone now, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 那你唱那个
Katrina: Then sing that one.
Jack: 那那那来点甜甜的吧
Jack: Let's sing something sweet then.
Katrina: 你唱那个
Katrina: Sing that one.
Katrina: 恋爱ING吧反正你也是恋爱ING
Katrina: Love ING, since you're in love ING.
Shure: 恋爱ING的词是什么来着
Shure: What's the lyrics to Love ING again?
Shure: 那那有点唱不上去
Shure: That one's a bit hard to sing.
男嘉宾:情非得已
Male Guest: Can't Help Falling in Love.
Katrina: 情非得已也行
Katrina: Can't Help Falling in Love is fine too.
男嘉宾:有何不可
Male Guest: Why not?
Katrina: 唱素颜吧
Katrina: Sing Bare Face.
Alice:我鞋呢
Alice: Where are my shoes?
Katrina: 对着你女朋友唱素颜
Katrina: Sing Bare Face to your girlfriend.
Jake:哎唱素颜了
Jake: Hey, sing Bare Face.
Alice:我这人不爱穿鞋有什么毛病
Alice: I don't like wearing shoes, what's the problem?
Katrina: 你女朋友给你唱那个
Katrina: Your girlfriend sings that one.
Katrina: 她唱女生不
Katrina: Does she sing female parts?
男嘉宾:来点那什么小小那个
Male Guest: Sing that small, small one.
Shure: 来嘛
Shure: Come on.
Katrina: 素颜嘛
Katrina: Bare Face.
Shure: 唱一个素颜来了
Shure: Sing Bare Face, let's go.
Shure: 素颜来了
Shure: Bare Face, let's go.
Katrina: 来嘛
Katrina: Come on.
Shure: 行
Shure: Alright.
Jack: 素颜 素颜
Jack: Bare Face, Bare Face.
Shure: 来给我给我也整一杯
Shure: Come on, pour me a glass too.
Shure的女友:还有杯子吗
Shure's GF: Are there any cups left?
Shure的女友:这没杯子了吗
Shure's GF: Are there no cups left?
Shure: 你能可以只弹左手
Shure: Can you play it with just your left hand?
Shure: 刘帅要不你替我弹
Shure: Choiszt, why don't you play for me?
Choiszt: 我没听过你弹这个
Choiszt: I've never heard you play this.
Shure: 你弹弹就行
Shure: Just play, you'll be fine.
Shure: 哎OK OK
Shure: Oh, okay, okay.
男嘉宾:喂 喂
Male Guest: Hello, hello.
Shure: 怎么还整俩碗呢
Shure: Why are there two bowls?
Shure: 结拜了是吗
Shure: Are we swearing brotherhood?
Katrina: 哎这是啥意思
Katrina: Hey, what does this mean?
Shure: 我要那 就要 还没
Shure: I want that one, just that one, not yet.
Alice:刘婷你喝不喝
Alice: Liu Ting, are you drinking or not?
Alice:你别喝了
Alice: Don't drink.
Alice:小孩不让喝酒
Alice: Kids aren't allowed to drink.
Shure: 可以可以哇哈哈哈
Shure: Okay, okay, hahaha.
男嘉宾:用碗
Male Guest: Use a bowl.
Shure: 你说啥
Shure: What did you say?
Alice:没杯子
Alice: No cups.
Shure: 纯饮一碗是吧
Shure: Drink a whole bowl straight, right?
Katrina: 农夫山泉微醺水
Katrina: Nongfu Spring mildly alcoholic water.
Jack: 可以可以
Jack: Okay, okay.
Shure: 随便随便
Shure: Whatever, whatever.
Katrina: 行你两个小时确实有点
Katrina: Yeah, you really took two hours.
Lucia:一顿乱回
Lucia: A whole mess.
Jack: 可以啊 厉害呀
Jack: It's fine, impressive.
Jake:手挺狠啊
Jake: Your hand is pretty tough.
Jack: 要喝好啊
Jack: Drink well.
Katrina: 拜拜拜拜
Katrina: Bye, bye.
Shure: 哎呀不好
Shure: Oh no, not good.
Katrina: 那我把他送到门口吧走吧
Katrina: I'll take him to the door, let's go.
Alice:你要吗你要吗
Alice: Do you want it, do you want it?
Alice:我给你找个容器
Alice: I'll find you a container.
Jack: 啥也不可以
Jack: Nothing is fine.
Alice:我给你拿个
Alice: I'll get you one.
Katrina: 你知咋出去不虽然我自已也不在
Katrina: Do you know how to get out? Although I'm not here myself.
Alice:拿个容器
Alice: Get a container.
Alice:虽然我自己也不在 我来都来了
Alice: Although I'm not here myself, but I'm here.
Jake:哎呀 我真傻
Jake: Oh, I'm really dumb.
Shure: 哎哟 嗨 嗨 嗨 嗨 嗨
Shure: Oh hey hey hey hey hey
Shure: 还有还有还有还有还有还有还有还有
Shure: There's more, there's more, there's more, there's more
Jake: 真傻了这个哈哈哈
Jake: This is really silly, haha
Jake:你也正好壮点胆
Jake: You should also gather some courage
Jake:对 报应
Jake: Yeah, it's karma
Shure: 你你你先溜了吧
Shure: You you you better sneak off first
Shure: 你先找一会去吧你
Shure: Go find something to do first
Alice:刘婷拿个巧克力
Alice: Liu Ting, grab a chocolate
Jake:哎人呢
Jake: Hey, where is everyone?
Shure: 对
Shure: Right
Jake:哦好这就是我们5天的排练结果
Jake: Oh great, this is the result of our 5 days of rehearsal
Shure: 我给你给你
Shure: I'll give it to you, I'll give it to you
Shure: 声音开小点好不好哦
Shure: Can you turn down the volume a bit?
Jake:十分默契
Jake: Perfectly in sync
Shure: 人没上来
Shure: People haven't arrived yet
Lucia:基本上只能靠默契
Lucia: Basically, we can only rely on our teamwork
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no
Shure: 一般一般一般
Shure: Just average, just average
Shure: 这个这个
Shure: This this
Jake:你呀 你
Jake: You, you
Jake:这个数据集是不是全球独一份 老板
Jake: Is this dataset unique in the world, boss?
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed
Shure: 就我们这数据集的价值我跟你讲
Shure: The value of this dataset, let me tell you
Shure: 无可估量
Shure: It's priceless
Shure: 我开始学老板反向画饼哈哈哈
Shure: I've started learning how to sell dreams like the boss, haha
Jake:太 确实
Jake: Too true
Shure: 来吧你给我倒回去吧
Shure: Come on, rewind it for me
Shure: 放这吧放这吧
Shure: Put it here, put it here
Shure: 我倒回去
Shure: I'll rewind it
Jake:就朝着弱智吧那路去了
Jake: Heading straight down the path of idiocy
Shure: 我们我们
Shure: We, we
Shure: 这个是人类
Shure: This is humanity
Shure: 其实是一些正常的活动
Shure: Actually, these are just normal activities
Jake:哎正常活动
Jake: Normal activities
Jake:都很正常
Jake: All very normal
Shure: 不不不造作
Shure: Not pretentious
Shure: 不
Shure: No
Jake:就 就你不喝酒就唱不上去
Jake: You just can't sing well without drinking
Jake:这很的
Jake: That's the truth
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes
Jake:对 这个就
Jake: Yeah, this...
Shure: AI根本想不到这点对吧
Shure: AI wouldn't think of this, right?
Shure: 能啊
Shure: It can.
Jack: 你错过了
Jack: You missed it.
Jake:再来一次
Jake: Try again.
Jack: 精彩发言
Jack: Great speech.
男嘉宾:你说高不高呢
Male Guest: Do you think it's high?
Jack: 这样
Jack: Like this.
Jack: 这你 你先说
Jack: You, you go first.
Jack: 你说高不高吧
Jack: Do you think it's high?
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 哎我靠
Shure: Hey, damn it.
Shure: 来吧女嘉宾
Shure: Come on, female guest.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
男嘉宾:刚刚喝酒干嘛呢
Male Guest: What were you doing when you were drinking?
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
男嘉宾:你已经忘了喝酒干嘛了
Male Guest: You've already forgotten why you were drinking.
Jake:呵呵看来喝挺多
Jake: Haha, looks like you drank quite a lot.
男嘉宾:已经倒半天了
Male Guest: It's been pouring for a while.
男嘉宾:嗯
Male Guest: Hmm.
Alice:别玩抽象
Alice: Don't play abstract.
Shure: 词写上了
Shure: The word is written.
Jake:有 有词有词
Jake: Yes, there's a word.
Shure: 呃你稍微放大一点
Shure: Uh, just enlarge it a bit.
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh.
Shure: 刘帅好OK
Shure: Choiszt, okay.
Shure: 然后你来翻谱对OK
Shure: Then you flip the score, okay?
Jake:我 我来给你播
Shure: 这回能看清了吧
Shure: You can see it clearly now, right?
Shure: 我
Shure: I...
男嘉宾:倒酒
Male Guest: Pour the wine.
Shure: 来吧来吧拿 过来
Shure: Come on, come on, take it over.
Alice:我给你拿个勺子类的东西
Alice: I'll get you something like a spoon.
Shure: 来吧准备
Shure: Come on, get ready.
Shure: 可以了
Shure: That's enough.
Alice:你修修图啊稍等我
Alice: You fix the picture, wait for me.
Shure:  一段就可以了
Shure: Just one part is enough.
Jack: 你有没有拍下去呢
Jack: Did you capture it?
男嘉宾:刚刚发生了什么
Male Guest: What just happened?
Jake:啊没看见
Jake: Ah, didn't see it.
Alice:什么什么什么
Alice: What, what, what?
Alice:波啦
Alice: Bola.
Jake:OK OK没关系这边有个机会
Jake: OK OK, no worries, there's a chance here.
Alice:哎呀
Alice: Oh no.
Katrina: 我今天晚上受不了了
Katrina: I can't handle it tonight.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 啊真难受
Katrina: Ah, it's really uncomfortable.
Katrina: 点一首唯一
Katrina: Play "The Only One".
Alice:在来一块
Alice: Another piece.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Nicous: 小黄 唱吧
Nicous: Nicous, sing it.
Katrina: E了
Katrina: E'd it.
Shure: 您来唱
Shure: You sing.
Katrina: 真E了
Katrina: Seriously E'd it.
男嘉宾:咱心里
Male Guest: In our hearts.
男嘉宾:也是难以
Male Guest: It's also hard.
Tasha:也是男女
Tasha: It's also boys and girls.
Shure: 我不会
Shure: I can't.
Shure的女友:那首我真不会
Shure's GF: I really can't sing that one.
Shure的女友:这首还唱过
Shure's GF: I've sung this one before.
Shure的女友:那首真不会
Shure's GF: That one I really can't.
男嘉宾:OK
Male Guest: OK.
男嘉宾:告五人的是不是王力宏的
Male Guest: Is the Five People version of Leehom Wang's?
Shure: 对 告5人的
Shure: Yes, it's Five People's.
Shure: 告五人的
Shure: Five People's.
Shure: 告5人的
Shure: 告五人你弹的是王力宏的
Shure: Five People, you're playing Leehom Wang's version.
Shure: 你谈的是王力宏的啊
Shure: You're playing Leehom Wang's, huh?
男嘉宾:这是告五人的吗
Male Guest: Is this Five People’s?
Jack: 啊告五人
Jack: Ah, Five People.
Jack: 这这这跟那个有什么区别吗
Jack: What's the difference with that one?
Nicous: 是两个两个
Nicous: It's two different ones.
Shure: 完全不一样的歌
Shure: Completely different songs.
Nicous: 完全不一样
Nicous: Completely different.
Shure: 两种不一样
Shure: Two different kinds.
Jack: 哦
Jack: Oh.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Katrina: 我真的能唱吗
Katrina: Can I really sing?
Shure: 你可以的
Shure: You can do it.
Katrina: 来
Katrina: Come on.
Shure: 你不行少和弦就行
Shure: You can't do it, just skip some chords.
Katrina: 你帮我合着点
Katrina: Can you help me with the chords?
Shure: 我还帮你合着点
Shure: You want me to help with the chords?
Katrina: 就大家帮我合着点
Katrina: Just everyone help me with the chords.
Katrina: 我一个人唱我的声音我会觉得很尴尬
Katrina: Singing alone makes me feel awkward.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 我看从哪开始
Katrina: Let me see where to start.
Katrina: 我靠挺好我不知道从哪进
Katrina: Wow, I don't know where to come in.
Alice:吃提拉米苏吗我给你切一块
Alice: Want some tiramisu? I'll cut you a piece.
Katrina: 你能提示一下吗
Katrina: Can you give me a cue?
Lucia:我下午吃了
Lucia: I had some this afternoon.
Alice:他说挺好吃的
Alice: He said it was really good.
Lucia:对我也觉得挺好吃的
Lucia: Yeah, I thought it was really good too.
Lucia:是吧
Lucia: Right?
Katrina: 我也觉得
Katrina: I think so too.
Alice:吃提拉米苏吗我给你切一块
Alice: Want some tiramisu? I'll cut you a piece.
Shure: 哎我直接弹了得了
Shure: Hey, I'll just play it.
Shure: 来吧来吧
Shure: Come on, let's go.
Shure的女友:我吃过了
Shure's GF: I've already eaten.
Alice:你要吗
Alice: Do you want it?
Lucia:我们俩一起吃的
Lucia: We ate together.
Shure: 你这怎么D调你知道吗
Shure: Do you know how to change this to D key?
Alice:你要吗给你切一下
Alice: Do you want it? I can cut it for you.
男嘉宾:我从来不用这些
Male Guest: I never use these.
Alice:我得给你找个容器
Alice: I need to find a container for you.
Shure: 我草
Shure: Oh crap.
Shure: 你给我移个调我就可以可以
Shure: If you change the key for me, I can do it.
Alice:给你用这个吧
Alice: Use this then.
Katrina: 这是在干什么呢
Katrina: What are you guys doing?
Alice:你在乱叫
Alice: Stop shouting.
Alice:妈我杀了你
Alice: Mom, I'll kill you.
Shure: 等一下啊
Shure: Hold on.
Shure: 我稍等我稍微移个调就可以
Shure: 你怎么移调啊
男嘉宾:这歌你没听过吗
Shure: 哎
Katrina: 没听过吗
Nicous: 哦这这这这这个
Nicous: Oh, this, this, this one.
Jake:这两天来少了
Jake: Haven't seen you around much these days.
男嘉宾:不会每天都唱吧
Male Guest: You don't sing every day, right?
Katrina: 每天都唱这首歌一到晚上
Katrina: I sing this song every night.
Jake:每天都唱
Jake: Every day.
Shure: 要不这个我帮你弹
Shure: How about I play it for you?
男嘉宾:啊
Male Guest: Ah.
Jack: 哦
Jack: Oh.
Shure: 你这调对吗你想想
Shure: Is your tune right? Think about it.
Alice:露西亚让我过一下下
Alice: Lucia, let me pass through.
Lucia:啊好的
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Alice:哎我看有点
Alice: Hey, I see a bit...
Lucia:这个呃是不是还要在
Lucia: This, uh, does it need to...
Alice:噢噢谢谢
Alice: Oh, oh, thanks.
Lucia:没事
Lucia: No problem.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake:谢彬竹没搞定
Jake: Xie Binzhu didn't get it done.
Shure: 你就全程在这翻手机
Shure: You're just scrolling through your phone the whole time.
Shure: 你在你在后面有什么用
Shure: What good are you in the back?
Shure: 四级
Shure: Level four.
Shure: 然后你往上移半个调不就得了吗
Shure: Then just move up half a note, won't that work?
Shure: 笨死了可
Shure: You're so dumb.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Katrina: 从头吗
Katrina: From the top?
Jack: 从头吧
Jack: From the top.
Shure: OK能不能找到了哥
Shure: Okay, can you find it, bro?
Shure: 这次
Shure: This time...
Shure: 这这次
Shure: This, this time...
Shure: 那我就给你声开大点了啊
Shure: Let me turn up the volume for you.
Alice:要哪个
Alice: Which one?
Shure: 真没有问题了
Shure: No problem now.
Shure: 哈哈哈哎
Shure: Hahaha, hey.
Nicous: 准备
Nicous: Ready.
Jake:你又行了了是吧
Jake: You're good again, right?
Shure: 他又行了
Shure: He's good again.
Alice:行
Alice: Okay.
Shure: 能不能找到他哥
Shure: Can you find him, bro?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 那刚才不是完事了吗
Shure: Didn't we just finish it?
Alice:能给我发个消息吗找不着你了
Alice: Can you send me a message? I can't find you.
Shure: 好终于对上了
Shure: Finally, it's right.
Alice:太卡了
Alice: It's too laggy.
Shure: 你在你在后面有什么用
Shure: What are you doing back there?
Katrina: 来
Katrina: Come here.
Alice:搜不到
Alice: Can't find it.
Jake:你真的懂
Jake: You really understand this.
Jake:呀
Jake: Ah.
Katrina: OK哦
Katrina: Okay!
Katrina: 换下一首
Katrina: Next song.
Shure: 还有要表演的同学
Shure: Anyone else wants to perform?
男嘉宾:靖康
Male Guest: Jingkang.
Shure: 靖康你会唱什么
Shure: Jingkang, what can you sing?
Katrina: 唱一首
Katrina: Sing a song.
Shure: 这老板得唱一首吧
Shure: The boss has to sing a song, right?
Shure: 唱什么老板啊
Shure: What will the boss sing?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
男嘉宾:你会唱什么
Male Guest: What can you sing?
Katrina: 爱拼才会赢
Katrina: "Love to Win."
Jake:行来
Jake: Alright, let's go.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: 老板真会唱吗
Shure: Can the boss really sing?
Jake:不会
Jake: No.
Shure: 老板会会
Shure: The boss can sing.
Shure: 会唱点什么吗
Shure: Can you sing something?
Alice:yes OK
Alice: Yes, OK.
女嘉宾:are you OK
Female Guest: Are you OK?
Jake:are you OK
Jake: Are you OK?
Alice:他的手机铃声
Alice: It's his ringtone.
Jake:are you OK这个倒是可以
Jake: "Are you OK" is fine.
Shure: 哎呦
Shure: Oh my.
Lucia:婧康的手机铃声
Lucia: Jingkang's ringtone.
Alice:are you OK
Alice: Are you OK?
Jake:are you OK
Alice:hello
Alice: Hello.
Shure: 那我
Shure: Then I...
Shure: 这怎么办呢
Shure: What should I do?
Shure: 这这大家以后你看
Shure: Everyone, look at this in the future.
Shure: 这就是一个情商小课堂
Shure: This is an emotional intelligence class.
男嘉宾:富士山下
Male Guest: "Under Mt. Fuji."
男嘉宾:哦
Male Guest: Oh.
Jack: 可以可以
Jack: Alright, alright.
Alice:我现在就去山东进修
Alice: I'm going to Shandong to study now.
Shure: 可以
Alice:呃山东
Alice: Uh, Shandong
Alice:呃哈哈哈哈
Alice: Uh hahaha
Alice:情商小课堂
Alice: Emotional intelligence class
Shure: are you OK哈喽
Shure: Are you OK? Hello
Lucia:我靠
Lucia: Oh my god
Shure: 老板来
Shure: Boss, come here
Shure: 我觉得这样也可以
Shure: I think this way is also fine
Shure: 咱们也不尴尬
Shure: We won't be awkward either
Jake:用不着用不着
Jake: No need, no need
Jake:用不着
Jake: No need
Jake:用不着用不着
Jake: No need, no need
Shure: 要成功哈哈哈
Shure: Gonna succeed, hahaha
Jake:先打
Jake: Let's start first
Lucia:不是谁是老板啊
Lucia: Who is the boss anyway?
Shure: 老板老板
Shure: Boss, boss
Jake:用不着
Jake: No need
Jake:用不着用不着
Jake: No need, no need
Jake:呃算了
Jake: Uh, never mind
Jake:哈哈挺会
Jake: Haha, pretty good
Katrina: 这弹啥了
Katrina: What did you play?
Shure: 他把老板的歌词给弹了
Shure: He played the boss's song
Shure: 这种一般都怎么处理呢
Shure: How do you usually handle this?
Alice:送去山东
Alice: Send him to Shandong
Jack: 不趁着人多的时候说话知道不
Jack: Don't talk when there are too many people, you know
Shure: 我感觉这样
Shure: I feel like
Shure: 明天他左脚就可能踏进公司了吧
Shure: Tomorrow he might step into the company with his left foot
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh
Katrina: 那个唱富士山下
Katrina: The one singing "Under the Mount Fuji"
Shure: 所以所以XBZ
Shure: So, so, XBZ
Jack: 可以
Jack: Okay
Shure: 你你在这里的
Shure: You, you are here
Katrina: 起一个什么作用呢
Katrina: What's your role here?
Shure: 气氛组
Shure: Atmosphere team
Katrina: 起一个logo作用哈哈哈
Katrina: Like a logo, hahaha
Shure: logo怎么这牌子
Shure: Logo, how about this brand
Shure: 打钱了是吗
Shure: Did they pay?
Katrina: 唱点经典的
Katrina: Sing some classics
Katrina: 大家都会的
Katrina: Ones everyone knows
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Katrina: 周杰伦陈奕迅
Katrina: Jay Chou and Eason Chan.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Jack: 可不可以又弹又跳一条龙
Jack: Can you do a one-man band performance?
男嘉宾:这有点难
Male Guest: That's a bit difficult.
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hello.
Shure: 没事看看你
Shure: No worries, just checking on you.
Shure: 没事 不用不用
Shure: It's okay, no need.
Katrina: 这个词有点难看到
Katrina: This word is a bit hard to see.
Shure: 对你这上不了桌回家的时候
Shure: Yeah, you can't bring this to the table when you get home.
Shure: 现在先坐小孩的时候历练2年
Shure: For now, sit down, and train for 2 years.
Shure: 哼 什么好的好的
Shure: Huh, what? Okay, okay.
Alice:好吗
Alice: Is that okay?
Alice:好的
Alice: Okay.
Katrina: 好吧好的
Katrina: Alright, fine.
Alice:好的
Alice: Okay.
Alice:大兵打人装修吗
Alice: The soldier hit someone, is it true?
男嘉宾:来一个来一个来一个
Male Guest: Give it a try, give it a try.
Alice:再来一块吗还吃吗
Alice: Do you want another piece, still eating?
Jack: 给你拿麦  我给你拿麦
Jack: I'll get you the mic, I'll get you the mic.
Shure: 这太浓了
Shure: This is too strong.
Jack: 我负责给你拿麦
Jack: I'll handle the mic for you.
Shure: 就跟我
Shure: Just like with me.
Shure: 要不给我就稍微倒一点
Shure: If you can't give it to me, just pour a little.
Alice:有但是太杂了这根本就没有一个
Alice: Yeah, but it's too mixed, there's no clear one.
Shure: 陈奕迅啊这是
Shure: This is Eason Chan.
Shure: 兑一起然后再分一半
Shure: Mix it together, then split it in half.
Shure: 我给他录一个
Shure: I'll record one for him.
Lucia:哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, that's impressive.
Shure: 啊他那天说的
Shure: Ah, he said that day...
Shure: 哇谢彬竹
Shure: Wow, Xie Bin Zhu.
Shure: 终于默契了一次
Shure: Finally, we got it right once.
Shure: 我懂了问题出在我身上
Shure: I understand now, the problem is with me.
Shure: 不是不是你身上
Shure: Not with you.
Shure: 懂了懂了
Shure: Got it, got it.
Shure: 跟跟跟那个帅师傅比较
Shure: Compared to the master, right?
Shure: 比较投缘是吧
Shure: We get along better, right?
Nicous: 下一个
Nicous: Next.
Shure: 下一个
Shure: Next.
Jake:哎别你别你别
Jake: Hey, no, don't, don't.
Shure: 靠 好
Shure: Damn, okay.
Nicous: 你来一个
Nicous: You do one.
Jake:对你来一个
Jake: Yeah, you do one.
男嘉宾:不用啦
Male Guest: No need.
Shure: 我们有全民K歌
Shure: We have KTV for everyone.
Katrina: 实在不行普通朋友
Katrina: If it really doesn't work, just a regular friend.
男嘉宾:普通朋友
Male Guest: Just a regular friend.
Katrina: 大家一起唱就没事
Katrina: If everyone sings together, it's fine.
Katrina: 来来来
Katrina: Come on, come on.
Katrina: RNB是非常适合这种氛围的
Katrina: R&B is really fitting for this vibe.
Katrina: 没关系挺可爱
Katrina: It's okay, it's pretty cute.
Katrina: 没事
Katrina: It's fine.
Shure的女友:都很喜欢
Shure's GF: Everyone likes it.
Jack: 给给给找个词呗
Jack: Give, give, give, find some lyrics.
男嘉宾:哦
Male Guest: Oh.
Shure: 发完了记得删
Shure: Remember to delete it after sending.
Shure: 别被你女朋友发现了
Shure: Don't let your girlfriend find out.
Shure: 你不是孤优从立
Shure: You're not a loner.
Jake:把手扳了
Jake: Bend your hand.
Shure: 很好
Shure: Very good.
Shure: 加入了最后一句
Shure: Added the last line.
Shure: 具有个人特色的rap部分
Shure: With a personal touch of rap.
Shure: 这谢彬竹每次最后一下叮一下就是哎
Shure: This Xie Binzhu always adds a finishing touch at the end.
Shure: 非点睛一下
Shure: Can't miss the highlight.
Shure: 就是除了内我基本没听清哈哈哈
Shure: Besides that, I basically didn't catch anything haha.
Nicous: 两条进不去啊没歌词
Nicous: Two lines can't go in without lyrics.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 好该谁了
Shure: Alright, whose turn is it?
Shure: 到谁了
Shure: Who's next?
Katrina: 会弹的不就你们两个吗
Katrina: Aren't you two the ones who can play?
男嘉宾:对呀
Male Guest: Yes.
Katrina: 点歌呗
Katrina: Pick a song.
Shure: 主要我我唱的
Shure: Mainly I, I sing.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 你点个呗
Katrina: You pick one.
Shure: 好别摘不下来
Shure: Okay, don't take it off.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 这个这个呢
Shure: This one, this one.
男嘉宾:好摘
Male guest: Easy to take off.
Shure: 那如果摘不下来呢
Shure: What if it doesn't come off?
男嘉宾:好摘
Male guest: Easy to take off.
Shure: 哦只要不丢就行
Shure: Oh, as long as it doesn't get lost, it's fine.
Shure: 但是手指手指可以去是吧
Shure: But fingers, fingers can go, right?
Nicous: 这什么
Nicous: What's this?
Shure: 淘汰
Shure: Elimination.
Katrina: 前面怎么唱来着
Katrina: How did the song go in the front?
Shure: 这也不能顶
Shure: You can't top this either.
Shure: 那我那我先摘一个
Shure: Then I'll, I'll take one off first.
Shure: 摘不下来的时候
Shure: When it doesn't come off.
Shure的女友:哎呀别别别别别
Shure's GF: Hey, don't, don't, don't, don't, don't.
Shure: 到时候跟我妈妈哭
Shure: Then I'll cry to my mom.
Shure: 妈妈你看
Shure: Mom, look.
Shure: 他把我这个戒指抢走还摘不下来
Shure: He took my ring and it won't come off.
Shure: 妈给他剁了哈
Shure: Mom, chop it off for him.
Shure的女友:我知道不能丢
Shure's GF: I know it can't be lost.
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay, okay.
Shure的女友:这个丢了我真哭给你看
Shure's GF: If it's lost, I'll really cry for you.
Shure: 我知道我知道
Shure: I know, I know.
Katrina: 受不了了
Katrina: I can't take it anymore.
Katrina: 这对小情侣
Katrina: This couple.
Katrina: 我怎么看不清词啊
Katrina: Why can't I see the lyrics clearly?
Shure: 几天怎么这么爱我
Shure: How come you're so in love with me these days?
Shure: 多爽啊
Shure: It's so great.
Shure: 还每天能拿300块
Shure: Plus, I can get 300 bucks every day.
Shure的女友:没有其实每个周末跟你出去玩的话
Shure's GF: Actually, if we hang out every weekend.
Katrina: 直接拍情侣写真了
Katrina: Just take couple photos directly.
Shure的女友:会是在正常生活中
Shure's GF: It would be in normal life.
Jake:草 这他妈怎么起来
Jake: Damn, how do you get up?
Shure的女友:然后出现一点很失去的情况
Shure's GF: And then there would be a bit of a lost situation.
Shure的女友:但是特别好
Shure's GF: But it's really good.
Shure的女友:只要我正常生活也没有什么很好的
Shure's GF: As long as I live normally, there's nothing much.
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes.
Katrina: 哎  哎哟什么时候我也有男朋友
Katrina: Ah, when will I have a boyfriend too?
Shure: 无妨
Shure: Doesn't matter.
Katrina: 拍一个哈哈哈
Katrina: Take a photo, haha.
Lucia:前面那些歌我都没听过
Lucia: I haven't heard those songs before.
Alice:你应该不怎么听中文歌吧
Alice: You probably don't listen to Chinese songs much, right?
Lucia:我听得比较少
Lucia: I listen to them less often.
Lucia:因为我有几个很喜欢的歌手
Lucia: Because I have a few favorite singers.
Shure的女友:就你知道他们在那找吗
Shure's GF: Do you know where to find them?
Lucia:然后听他们听的比较多
Lucia: And I listen to them a lot.
Shure的女友:我上回跟Darry和顾老师
Shure's GF: Last time, I went to sing with Darry and Teacher Gu.
Lucia:所以留下的听别的歌的时间就很少
Lucia: So I have very little time left to listen to other songs.
Shure的女友:两个人去唱歌玩
Shure's GF: The two of us went to sing.
Shure的女友:那天你也知道
Shure's GF: You know that day.
Jake:走道没了
Jake: The hallway was gone.
Shure的女友:然后就是我说陈奕迅OK这首
Shure's GF: And then I said, "Eason Chan, okay, this song."
Shure的女友:然后他们跟我说
Shure's GF: Then they told me...
Alice:有点困了
Alice: I'm a bit sleepy.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Shure的女友:就是我找那种
Shure's GF: I was looking for those kinds of songs.
Lucia:发现无法融入歌单
Lucia: I found it hard to fit into the playlist.
Shure的女友:我感觉大家都会唱的歌
Shure's GF: Songs that everyone can sing.
Lucia:变得I了起来
Lucia: It became awkward.
Shure的女友:他说OK这一首我好像知道
Shure's GF: He said, "Okay, I think I know this one."
Alice:没事你本来就I 无所谓
Alice: It's okay, you were already awkward, doesn't matter.
Shure的女友:但是我不会唱
Shure's GF: But I can't sing it.
Katrina: 周杰伦还有什么歌
Katrina: What other songs does Jay Chou have?
Shure的女友:然后你在说什么
Shure's GF: Then what are you talking about?
Shure的女友:那你为什么要找粤语歌
Shure's GF: Why are you looking for Cantonese songs?
Shure的女友:你找粤语歌
Shure's GF: You look for Cantonese songs.
Shure的女友:你不找伊森的歌
Shure's GF: You don't look for Eason's songs.
Shure的女友:什么东西
Shure's GF: What is this?
Shure的女友:最后唱的什么
Shure's GF: What was the last song?
Shure的女友:就是反正大家会唱粤语歌
Shure's GF: Anyway, everyone can sing Cantonese songs.
Shure的女友:但是唱的什么我也不知道
Shure's GF: But I don't know what they were singing.
Shure的女友:忘记了忘记了
Shure's GF: I forgot, forgot.
Shure: 东北人有自己的一套粤语体系
Shure: Northeasterners have their own Cantonese song system.
Shure: 知道吗哈哈哈哈
Shure: You know? Hahaha.
Shure的女友:不是啊戴瑞家山西的啊
Shure's GF: No, Darry's family is from Shanxi.
Lucia:好可爱
Lucia: So cute.
Alice:他没带走
女嘉宾:戴瑞是山西人
Female Guest: Darry is from Shanxi.
Katrina: 这我也听过
Katrina: I've heard this before.
Katrina: 这不是高中的时候
Katrina: Wasn't this in high school?
Shure的女友:我忘了山西哪里了
Shure's GF: I forgot which part of Shanxi.
Shure的女友:但反正是山西人
Shure's GF: But anyway, he's from Shanxi.
Lucia:不要拆散我们的小狗cp
Lucia: Don't break up our puppy couple.
Katrina: 听的诗班淡淡的
Katrina: The choir sounds so soft.
Lucia:刚好
Lucia: Just right.
Alice:那狗子CP
Alice: That dog couple.
Lucia:狗子CP嗯
Lucia: Dog couple, yeah.
Lucia:好可爱真可爱这花花也做得好好
Lucia: So cute, really cute. The flowers are also done so well.
Alice:你可以把这个头拆走
Alice: You can take this head off.
Katrina: 哈哈这首好适合吉他弹
Katrina: Haha, this song is perfect for guitar.
Lucia:我去找一个你拆
Lucia: I'll go find one, you take it apart.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Lucia:啊 谢谢
Lucia: Ah, thank you.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Alice:没事你喜欢的话你拿走也行
Alice: No problem, if you like it, you can take it.
Shure的女友:啊就是拍卖的开辟
Shure's GF: Ah, it's just the opening of the auction.
Shure的女友:已经不属于他的买家了是吗
Shure's GF: It no longer belongs to the buyer, right?
Jack: 对呀
Jack: Yeah.
Alice:对
Alice: Right.
Lucia:对对
Lucia: Yes, yes.
Jack: 啊好过分啊
Jack: Ah, that's so unfair.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:困了有点
Alice: I'm feeling a bit sleepy.
Alice:我真的困了
Alice: I'm really sleepy.
Shure: 自已倒啊
Shure: Pour it yourself then.
Shure的女友:气泡水和朗姆其实还可以
Shure's GF: Sparkling water and rum is actually okay.
Shure: 洗发水应该买的
Shure: Shampoo should be bought.
Shure的女友:但我感觉
Shure's GF: But I feel...
Shure的女友:我感觉它最好
Shure's GF: I feel it's best...
Shure的女友:其实是伏特加是最好的
Shure's GF: Actually, vodka is the best.
Shure的女友:但是不知道为什么你们没买
Shure's GF: But I don't know why you didn't buy it.
Shure: 我有半瓶一直说要带来的
Shure: I had half a bottle, always said I'd bring it.
Shure: 一直谁过来的时候都忘了带
Shure: Always forgot to bring it whenever I came.
Shure的女友:像罗舒兰这种东西
Shure's GF: Like something from Roseland.
Shure的女友:我觉得他只适合做少婷
Shure's GF: I think it's only suitable for making Shaoxing wine.
但Shure的女友:你买一瓶罗舒兰
Shure's GF: But you buy a bottle of Roseland...
Shure的女友:我其实不是很不是很理解
Shure's GF: I actually don't really... don't really understand.
Shure的女友:不是很理解就是这种
Shure's GF: I don't really understand this kind...
他虽然那个入口特别好
Shure's GF: Although it tastes really good...
Shure的女友:但是他他对我来说只适合做绍兴
Shure's GF: But to me, it's only suitable for making Shaoxing wine.
Shure的女友:前几年真的挺流行
Shure's GF: It was really popular a few years ago.
Shure的女友:真的
Shure's GF: Really.
Shure的女友:但是但是
Shure's GF: But, but...
Shure的女友:在网易云的那个归类里面
Shure's GF: On NetEase Cloud's categorization
Shure的女友:功德被归到了说唱
Shure's GF: The merit was classified as rap
Shure的女友:i mean the why
Shure's GF: I mean the why
Shure: 因为他有他有关联的
Shure: Because it has related elements
Shure: 比如说像豆芽这种课
Shure: For example, like courses about bean sprouts
Shure的女友:可能all right
Shure's GF: Maybe, all right
Shure: rap是多吧
Shure: Rap is a lot, right?
Shure: 又开始了
Shure: It's starting again
Shure的女友:对对对
Shure's GF: Yeah, yeah, yeah
Shure的女友:但他不是他不是
Shure's GF: But it's not, it's not
Shure的女友:他真的不是
Shure's GF: It really isn't
Shure的女友:你可以把归到任何一个类
Shure's GF: You could classify it under any category
Shure的女友:就是甚至你把归到华语大流行都行
Shure's GF: You could even put it under Mandarin pop
Shure的女友:但他真的不是说唱
Shure's GF: But it's really not rap
Shure的女友:其实你可以把我背到口中
Shure's GF: Actually, you could put me in your mouth
Shure的女友:我也不知道
Shure's GF: I don't know either
Shure的女友:音乐人的乐园
Shure's GF: The paradise of musicians
Shure: 谁知道
Shure: Who knows
Alice:我看着拉炼我呢
Alice: I'm looking at the zipper
Lucia:噢
Lucia: Oh
Alice:我一定看好吗
Alice: I'm definitely looking, okay?
Alice:我一定看啊
Alice: I'm definitely looking
Alice:结束了吗还是什么
Alice: Is it over or what?
Alice:这是干嘛
Alice: What's this for?
Alice:什么环节
Alice: What segment is this?
Lucia:无法融入歌单
Lucia: Can't fit into the playlist
Lucia:大部分都没听过
Lucia: Most haven't heard it
Shure: 给你胖了
Shure: Made you fat
Shure: 你不是怕被踢了
Shure: Weren't you afraid of being kicked out?
Alice:什么刘婷要唱凤凰传奇
Alice: What, Liu Ting wants to sing Phoenix Legend?
Shure的女友:高了高了高了
Shure's GF: Higher, higher, higher
Lucia:没有谱子
Lucia: No sheet music
Lucia:可是伴奏同学依然会弹
Lucia: But the accompanist still plays
Jack: 果然这个歌词你不会了
Jack: As expected, you don't know the lyrics
Alice:后面不会了
Alice: Don't know the later part
Jack: 找一下词好吗
Jack: Look up the lyrics, okay?
Shure的女友:啊不这种歌只要记住副歌就行
Shure's GF: Ah no, for this kind of song, just remember the chorus
Alice:凤凰传奇上
Alice: Phoenix Legend
刘婷:我其实也不太会唱
Liu Ting: Actually, I don't really know how to sing it either
Jake:再找一个再找一个
Jake: Find another one, find another one.
Jack: 除了副歌的词一遍也记不住
Jack: I can't remember anything except the chorus lyrics.
刘婷:主要是上吧
Liu Ting: Mainly just go for it.
Alice:上吧上吧
Alice: Go for it, go for it.
刘婷:图个氛围
Liu Ting: It's for the vibe.
刘婷:不是我会
Liu Ting: Not because I know it.
Shure: 不我们有
Shure: No, we have...
Shure: 我们有全民k歌这个软件的
Shure: We have this Karaoke app.
Shure: 你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Jack: 分分钟需要你
Jack: "Need You Every Minute."
男嘉宾:都不太会唱
Male Guest: No one can really sing it.
Shure的女友:啊不刚刚他就在啊
Sister: Ah, no, he was just here.
Shure的女友:刚刚还跟我说说为什么不能唱那个啊
Sister: He was just telling me why he couldn't sing that.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure的女友:就是就是就是
Sister: Yeah, yeah, exactly.
Shure: 我们有有有
Shure: We have, we have...
Shure: 全民k歌的
Shure: The Karaoke app.
Jack: 为什么没有唱吧之类的
Jack: Why don't we have "Sing It"?
Shure: 来来来我们是有的
Shure: Come on, we have it.
Shure: 大家
Shure: Everyone.
Jack: 吉他这边就自个看
Jack: Just look at the guitar part yourself.
Jack: 然后我们另外一个手机
Jack: Then we'll use another phone.
Jack: 放在KTV的那个
Jack: Put it in the KTV system.
男嘉宾:对对对来吧
Male Guest: Yeah, yeah, let's do it.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Shure: 我们其实早就为了这个k歌程序的啊
Shure: We actually prepared for this Karaoke app.
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
男嘉宾:婧康真的不要高歌一曲
Male Guest: Jingkang, really don't sing a song?
男嘉宾:这可是我们宝贵的数据资源车呀
Male Guest: This is our precious data resource!
Alice:今天
Alice: Today.
男嘉宾:468861哦你摄影他就要拍了
Male Guest: 468861, oh, you're filming, he's going to shoot.
男嘉宾:然后就不会说两个一起的
Male Guest: Then he won't say two together.
男嘉宾:也有道理啊
Male Guest: Makes sense.
Tasha:把电脑拿给我呗
Tasha: Give me the laptop.
Shure: 唉好
Shure: Oh, okay.
Tasha:还有 对
Tasha: And, yeah.
Tasha:搞不完了快
Tasha: We can't finish, hurry.
Shure的女友:你可以就是
Sister: You can just...
Alice:写完
Alice: Finish writing.
男嘉宾:陈奕迅的粤语歌词
Male Guest: Eason Chan's Cantonese lyrics.
男嘉宾:我的粤语都是来吧
Male Guest: My Cantonese is all "come on".
Shure: 来吧咱们
Shure: Come on, let's do this.
Shure: 咱们可以点了
Shure: We can order now.
男嘉宾:海阔天空
Male Guest: Boundless sky.
Jack: 我来搜一搜
Jack: Let me look it up.
男嘉宾:因为我去KTV就唱了哪些歌
Male Guest: Because when I go to KTV, I sing those songs.
Nicous: 我下班了吧
Nicous: I'm off work now, right?
Shure: 对你可以下班了
Shure: Yeah, you can clock out now.
Shure: 操
Shure: Damn.
Shure: 咱开 4块钱
Shure: We offer 4 bucks.
Shure: 4块钱杨老板能报一下不到1新币
Shure: 4 bucks, Jake. It's less than 1 SGD.
Jake:多少钱
Jake: How much is it?
男嘉宾:4块
Male Guest: 4 bucks.
Shure: 4块
Shure: 4 bucks.
Jake:4块多少新币
Jake: How much in SGD?
Shure: 0.8新币
Shure: 0.8 SGD.
Jake:那有点超预算了
Jake: That's a bit over budget.
Jake:哈哈哈买买买
Jake: Hahaha, buy, buy, buy!
男嘉宾:838080高
Male Guest: 838080 high.
女嘉宾:已经四五年了
Female Guest: It's been four or five years already.
男嘉宾:我我唱情非得已
Male Guest: I, I will sing "Qing Fei De Yi."
Jack: 他们有那个什么网
Jack: They have that thing, right?
Jack: 有那个什么情歌网
Jack: That love song website thing.
Shure的女友:麦给我麦给我
Shure's GF: Give me the mic, give me the mic.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 现在有吗
Shure: Is it working now?
Shure的女友:有有有
Shure's GF: Yes, yes, yes.
Shure: 有是吧
Shure: It is, right?
Shure: 有吧
Shure: It works, right?
Shure: OK OK
Shure: OK, OK.
Shure: 再再试一下
Shure: Let’s try again.
Shure: 现在有了OK
Shure: It's working now, OK.
Jack: 哎呀
Jack: Oh, man.
Shure: 稍等稍等
Shure: Hold on, hold on.
Shure: 我把把这个PPT退掉啊
Shure: Let me close this PPT.
Shure: OK OK这回就
Shure: OK, OK, now it should...
Shure: 我是不是应该打打个招呼说叔叔好
Shure: Should I say hello, like, "Hello, Uncle"?
Shure的女友:嫌我不好看
Shure's GF: Think I'm not good-looking?
Shure: XBZ就在这
Shure: XBZ is right here.
Shure: 跟个DJ一样
Shure: Like a DJ.
Shure的女友:摸鱼
Shure's GF: Slacking off
Shure: 但是他一个人被逮住了
Shure: But he got caught all alone
Shure的女友:摸鱼看摸鱼
Shure's GF: Slacking off, look at this
Shure: 我这数据不能要了
Shure: I can't use this data anymore
Jack: 情非得已来
Jack: Forced by circumstances, come on
Katrina: 来
Katrina: Here
Jack: 我切了啊
Jack: I'm cutting it off
Shure: 啊不不保存
Shure: Oh no, no, save it
Shure: 所有的都不保存你
Shure: Don't save any of it
Shure: 大家想让我保存吗
Shure: Do you all want me to save it?
Nicous: 唉 给他们存着
Nicous: Hey, save it for them
Shure: 第一个就是第一个就是
Shure: The first one, the first one is
Shure: 然后点开始唱歌对
Shure: Then start singing, right
Shure: 你稍微离近一点
Shure: Move a bit closer
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah
Shure: 为什么这首歌
Shure: Why this song?
Shure: 这首好像伴伴奏有点小
Shure: This one, the accompaniment seems a bit low
Shure: 爱上你了
Shure: I fell for you
Shure: 都录下来了
Shure: Got it all recorded
Shure的女友:起码让我刘海像个刘海好吗
Shure's GF: At least make my bangs look like bangs, alright?
Shure: 没有刚刚那音录下来哈哈
Shure: Didn't record that sound just now, haha
刘婷:是我的问题
Liu Ting: It's my fault
刘婷:脏话不是从你嘴里说出来的吗
Liu Ting: Didn't the swear words come out of your mouth?
Alice:脏话憋在心里心就脏了
Alice: If you hold back swear words, it taints your heart
Alice:说出来心就亮了
Alice: Saying them out makes your heart lighter
Shure的女友:发布一些假情报
Shure's GF: Spreading some false info
男嘉宾:搞点粤语歌哎
Male Guest: Let's do some Cantonese songs, hey
男嘉宾:哎你会唱粤语
Male Guest: Hey, can you sing Cantonese?
Shure的女友:今天中午跟我讲说你知道吗
Shure's GF: This noon you told me, you know what
Nicous: 来个海阔天空
Nicous: Sing "Boundless Oceans, Vast Skies"
Shure的女友:那个你舍友回家了
Shure's GF: Your roommate went home
男嘉宾:好好我不知道你是因为会粤语
Male Guest: Okay, I didn't know you knew Cantonese
Shure的女友:我说怎么可能
Shure's GF: How is that possible?
男嘉宾:还是你最喜欢陈奕迅
Male Guest: Or you like Eason Chan the most?
Shure的女友:我今天中午我吃完饭回回寝室的时候
Shure's GF: This noon, after lunch, when I returned to the dorm
男嘉宾:所以你陈奕迅的歌粤语的标准
Male Guest: So your Cantonese is as good as Eason Chan's
Shure的女友:他他他他刚买了两盒水果回来
Shure's GF: He just bought two boxes of fruits
Nicous: 等我来一个海阔天空我就下班
Nicous: I'll sing "Boundless Oceans, Vast Skies," then I'm off work
Shure的女友:他怎么可能回家了
Shure's GF: How could he have gone home?
Nicous: 下班海阔天空嗓子就没了没事
Nicous: After work, singing "Boundless Oceans, Vast Skies," my voice is gone, no worries
Shure的女友:我看到他跟他妈妈推出行李箱出去了
Shure's GF: I saw him and his mom pushing the suitcase out.
Shure的女友:我说不可能
Shure's GF: I said, no way.
Shure的女友:然后昨天晚上我回寝室的时候
Shure's GF: Then last night when I got back to the dorm,
Shure的女友:发现我的舍友在宿舍里面看电影
Shure's GF: I found my roommate watching a movie.
女嘉宾:开始
Female Guest: Start.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure的女友:就是加那种点燃咖啡加盐加柠檬
Shure's GF: It's like adding salt and lemon to a lit coffee.
Shure的女友:就是他真的只适合入手
Shure's GF: It's really just good for a try.
Shure的女友:虽然他入口性很很好但是
Shure's GF: Although it tastes good, but...
Shure的女友:他整个酒精的味道来讲
Shure's GF: In terms of overall alcohol flavor,
Shure的女友:调酒其实也行
Shure's GF: It could work as a cocktail.
Shure的女友:但是很爽
Shure's GF: But it's very refreshing.
Shure的女友:就是已经被验证
Shure's GF: It's already proven.
Shure的女友:大家喜欢的口味之外
Shure's GF: Besides the flavors that people like,
Shure的女友:或者说就是只是他去呃
Shure's GF: Or it's just for soaking, like...
Shure的女友:作为媒介去浸泡
Shure's GF: As a medium for soaking things like plums.
Shure的女友:包括呃青梅啊之类的一种东西来讲
Shure's GF: Aside from these methods,
Shure的女友:除了这些做法以外
Shure's GF: The most accepted way is to chop hands.
Shure的女友:他整个酒
Shure's GF: The whole alcohol...
Shure的女友:最被接受的做法就是剁手
Shure's GF: The most accepted method is chopping hands.
Shure的女友:我也不知道他在说什么
Shure's GF: I don't even know what he's talking about.
Shure的女友:但我想我本来就是
Shure's GF: But I think I was...
Shure的女友:Tims给安迪之后
Shure's GF: After Tims gave it to Andy,
Shure的女友:然后我发现
Shure's GF: Then I found out...
Shure的女友:周末然后我就直接就
Shure's GF: On the weekend, then I just...
Shure的女友:还有
Shure's GF: And then...
Shure: 啊我们还有一个香槟没开呢
Shure: Ah, we still have a bottle of champagne unopened.
男嘉宾:开 香槟那果酒呢
Male Guest: Open it. What about the fruit wine?
Shure: 有有
Shure: We've got it.
Jake:对 5%以上应该是
Jake: Yeah, it should be over 5%.
Shure的女友:有
Shure's GF: Yes.
Shure: 他不是香槟
Shure: It's not champagne.
Shure: 就是一个气泡酒
Shure: It's a sparkling wine.
Shure的女友:sorry我要看一下
Shure's GF: Sorry, I need to check.
Shure的女友:因为正常大概是在5-12度
Shure's GF: Normally, it's around 5-12 degrees.
Katrina: 这你们俩真的好专业
Katrina: You two are really professional.
Shure的女友:没有我不知道
Shure's GF: No, I don't know.
Shure的女友:快让他看
Shure's GF: Let him check quickly.
Shure的女友:sorry sorry sorry
Shure's GF: Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Jack: 老板不差钱
Jack: The boss isn't short of money.
Shure的女友:11度半 11.5
Shure's GF: 11 and a half degrees. 11.5.
Shure的女友:两只眼睛来看一下
Shure's GF: Look with both eyes
Shure的女友:如果没有晃的话
Shure's GF: If it doesn't shake
Jack: 已经录下了
Jack: It's already recorded
Shure的女友:他不会产生太多气泡
Shure's GF: It won't create too many bubbles
Shure: 我们
Shure: We
Shure: 楼上开还是楼下开啊
Shure: Should we turn it on upstairs or downstairs?
Shure: 楼下吧这设备太多了
Shure: Downstairs, there’s too much equipment here
Shure: 这碰
Shure: This is a mess
Shure的女友:不是一下又是你开
Shure's GF: Not again, you turn it on
Jack: 没事 漏得快没关系
Jack: It's okay, it leaks fast, no problem
Shure的女友:你管他楼上楼下呢
Shure's GF: Who cares, upstairs or downstairs
Shure的女友:你把你把
Shure's GF: You just
Shure的女友:你把谢彬竹当背景
Shure's GF: Use Xie Binzhu as background
Shure的女友:或者你到楼下当保姆
Shure's GF: Or go downstairs as a nanny
Shure: 不是就是这玩意碰上一个哪个都比我值钱好吗
Shure: No, it's just that anything here is worth more than me
Shure的女友:那洗手间就只是门锁不上
Shure's GF: The bathroom door just doesn’t lock
Shure: 那还有一位啊
Shure: There's another one
Shure的女友:那不是浴室吗
Shure's GF: Isn't that the shower?
Shure: 啊不是啊
Shure: No, it's not
Shure: 都是洗手间啊
Shure: They're all bathrooms
Jake:是
Jake: Yes
Shure: 没 不分干湿分离的
Shure: No, it's not separated by wet and dry areas
Shure: 快去快去快去
Shure: Hurry up, hurry up, hurry up
Shure的女友:你没跟我讲啊
Shure's GF: You didn't tell me
Shure: 对不起对不起
Shure: Sorry, sorry
Shure: 需要什么吗
Shure: Do you need anything?
Shure: 直接从这过就好
Shure: Just go through here
Shure: 帮你把灯开
Shure: Let me turn on the light for you
Shure: 是吗 啊啊
Shure: Really? Ah, ah